Avengers endgame is the culmination of
the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
here's an explanation of the end credits
now before we say anything else we have
to warn you this video contains spoilers
all previous 21 MCU films had a post
credit scene teasing what was coming
next in the series endgame takes a very
different approach there are no visuals
for the end scene instead we just hear
the sound of a hammer banging but there
is a deeper meaning behind it it's a
callback to Tony Stark building his
first suit in 2008 Iron Man which kicked
off the entire MCU
one of the main plot points of endgame
is time travel
while Scott laying is the one who
approaches the Avengers about the
possibility of it it's Tony Stark who
solves the problem and the solution
involves a mobius strip a mobius strip
is a very special type of mathematical
structure unlike a sphere or a cube it
only has one side you can see how this
works just by making one yourself take a
long strip of paper twist it once and
join the ends of it together now if you
take your pen and draw over it you can
mark the entire surface of the paper
without removing your pen so what does
this have to do with time travel well in
the film the heroes are faced with a
common dilemma why can't they just go
back in time and kill thanos as a baby
the problem with that is that time in
the film acts like a mobius strip you
can only travel in your current loop so
changing events in the past won't affect
the current timeline it'll create an
alternate timeline which is not what the
heroes want the heroes settle on a
different approach one that will have
just one outcome that they can control
travel back in time to get the stones
and use them to reverse the effects of
the snap and bring everybody back into
the current time so getting back to that
clanging sound it turns the entire MCU
into its own mobius strip these first 22
films are now called the Infinity Saga
which makes sense since a mobius strip
resembles the symbol for infinity watch
all 22 movies all the way through and
you end up back where you started with
Tony Stark making his first suit of
armor now this isn't the very first
scene that happens in the first Iron Man
movie but that first stark suit is the
kickoff for everything that comes after
so if the events of endgame have left
you sad over the loss of some fallen
heroes just know they're not really dead
they're in the infinite loop of time ha
ha very funny and since time travel now
exists in the MCU the possibility exists
that some of them could return
this is the nerdiest thing I've ever
done
[Music]
you
[Music]